moms we can all get very busy and we
have tendency to put ourselves last but
our next guest says it is time to step
in front of the line welcome Desi
Bartlett to the show Desi so great to
see you from beautiful Hawaii you got to
tell us how do we set these healthy
boundaries with our time
that's such a great question so I have
been working with two beautiful
co-authors Andrea orback and Nicole
Stewart on a book called total body
beautiful for the last two years and so
we have really had to learn how to set
boundaries with our time to write a book
together and and what I found is that if
we're really really clear with Our
intention about what it is that like
that we'd like to put forward into the
world it makes it much easier to say no
thank you or I'll call you back later so
one thing I'd like you to to protect is
your valuable time and when you see the
phone ring if your first instinct is to
go uh oh that's going to be half an hour
of my time that person is going to talk
my ear off and not even ask how I'm
doing I'm going to invite you to either
let it go to voicemail or to pick it up
and say hey can we talk another time I
really can't do this right now that is a
great tip another tip that you offer for
in the book is about staying present
tell me a little bit about that
yeah so we really wanted to focus on
mental physical and emotional health and
when we're talking about staying present
we're talking about really being in this
moment and not reviewing the past or
making future to-do lists and an easy
way to Anchor yourself in the present is
to Simply
watch your breath take a long slow
cleansing breath and it brings you right
back into the present and if you're
still feeling like oh my gosh I have
this you know big to-do list
if you simply try to stand and find your
balance on one foot I know it's a it's
sort of a silly little hack but if you
stand on one foot for 10 seconds and
then try the other foot for 10 seconds
you can't think about that to-do list
it'll bring you right into your body I'm
literally literally doing that right now
as we speak
let's talk about your third tip and this
is great it's about movement right
yeah so we want to try to get a little
bit of movement every single day that's
what our bodies are designed for and so
what I'd like for everyone to do is to
make an appointment especially busy
women you know we always put ourselves
last if it's between working out and
like going to do everything for our
families and our best friends we'll
we'll usually kind of say oh I need to
take care of others but there's
something called exercise adherence it's
just a fancy way of saying that you
stick with it and the way to stick with
it is increased by 50 if you have an
appointment it can be with your spouse
your best friend a trainer if that's
what you do or even the instructor at
the local gym if you just say hey I'm
going to see you tomorrow at four if you
know that someone is there waiting for
you and expecting you you're 50 more
likely to go and enjoy we cannot wait to
read the book what great tips really
putting ourselves first Desi thank you
so much for joining us and for the great
information we appreciate you so much
Ted I hope you're taking out some time
for yourself maybe like taking